let's go now to Sarah haret who's in Tel
Aviv and Sarah um Tel Aviv has been for
days very much the focal point of
protest demanding the captives release
we now have confirmation that they are
on Israeli soil what more can you tell
us uh We've literally just seen uh the
pictures of them uh arriving at one of
the Southern border towns to Gaza you
see people on the sides of the road ch
ING with the flags as the Convoy of
buses goes past and that's the latest
pictures that we've just seen now
confirming that they are in one of the
Southern borders of uh Israel on the
border with uh Gaza we've also in the
last few minutes had confirmation from
the Israeli military uh confirming that
uh apart from the 13 uh Israeli captives
the uh what are considered foreign
Nationals three tii and duel Israeli
Russian citizen they have now crossed
the Rafa Crossing they've also uh
crossed now through uh the Israeli um
checkpoint uh and are being helicoptered
as we speak uh to one of the hospitals
in uh the Tel Aviv area uh now that
means based on this that all of those
release now are in Israel yeah Sor it's
an important clarification that not all
of the captives have gone through the
same Crossing and that as you mentioned
there three the foreign Nationals have
gone South into Egypt the 13 Israelis uh
you said earlier had crossed through a
different Crossing how significant is
this do you
think that's correct well Israeli media
has been reporting that uh one of the
reasons for this was due to uh the 84y
old uh senior citizen uh an Israeli who
had to be helicopter directly uh to an
Israeli Hospital in the southern uh
border but it's still not clear as to
the reasons uh for this there's also
speculation as there has been often
without confirmation from uh the Israeli
uh government just yet speculation that
perhaps those that were held captive
this uh group of captives were actually
in uh Northern Gaza but of course no one
really knows because no one is at the
moment privy to any of these
Arrangements but it did definitely come
as a big surprise especially because uh
they were carried uh through uh using an
Israeli uh special unit they said they
were taken uh uh through the ground um
not across that uh Rafa border crossing
but straight away from Central Gaza
through a different uh Crossing now all
of this is also happening uh as uh the
war cab cabinet has been meeting uh not
far um from here just behind me actually
here in the ministry of Defense where
discussions are ongoing it seems as to
potentially looking at the possibility
which the US President Joe Biden spoke
about just uh earlier that looking at a
possibility of the extension of this
four day pause tomorrow is day four that
means that once tomorrow is over
according to what prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu has been saying now
for days as well as say the defense
minister AV Galant that they would
continue uh the war straight away as
soon as that four day pause is over well
now we're hearing from uh Israeli media
as well as from the US President Joe
Biden when he was asked what would his
preference be and he said to continue
this pause to enable and ensure that
more captives are released now it's
looking like that could be potentially
the direction that they're moving in
especially because Hamas a few days ago
went asked whether that was a
possibility
the spokesman did confirm that they were
looking at that that was an option they
would be interested in and in fact when
he was asked would that just be women
and children he said no it would also
include men so this is the direction
that they seem to be heading and that
certainly if you speak to anyone in this
Square here any of the relatives they'll
tell you that this is exactly what they
would like to see as well s and Tel Aviv
thank you